might seem like a great way to make some
quick money renting out your home or
rental property for a party
i'm here to tell you it's a bad idea one
week after metro police put out this psa
warning the community about the danger
of illegal party houses airbnb
is joining the effort to stop them we do
thank you for joining us on this friday
night on eight news now at 11 i'm brian
loftis
metro police say legal house parties
resulted in three deaths
they believe they're seeing a spike in
events because of course clubs bars
they're all closed for the most part
now airbnb is helping enforce these
rules locally
eight news now reporter sasha loft is
live now from a neighborhood where these
parties
have just been a nightmare for the
neighbors in that area
and really for everyone sasha
yes brian the neighbors in this
neighborhood here in the west valley say
that they have been dealing
with an absolute nightmare we're talking
about party buses
trash fights loud music and of course
very large gatherings
of people i spoke with one woman tonight
who says something
needs to be done
[Music]
when you drive through this neighborhood
it appears quiet
and peaceful they're not house parties
they're nightclubs
but once the sun goes down out of
control house parties
are taking over these streets near
buffalo and sahara
last week we had a fight at 3 30 in the
morning when is it
we had a naked man running down our
street the week before a neighbor we
spoke with
says it's really ramped up with covid 19
closures
with many gatherings over 250 people
promoted online these large gatherings
where people are not following
public health mandates they're
unacceptable that's why airbnb
is taking action they've suspended 20
listings across southern nevada
who violated their current ban on
parties and events
if you were a party promoter or a
property owner metro police
also released a psa last week warning
property owners
promoters and event organizers of the
serious consequences they could face
i'm here to tell you it's a bad idea but
those in this area
say so far this just isn't enough i
think they do a great job
most of the time but i think that
they're lacking they want
real action taken before something
serious happens
right in their backyard when is enough
enough
now if you would like to report an
airbnb listing violating the current
health
mandates and throwing a large gathering
or party we have information to do that
on our website
now anyone caught with an event or
gathering at their property that goes
against these health mandates
could face fines or even jail time
according to police
for now reporting live in the west
valley sasha loftis 8 news now